on Thursday the 19th of January 2023 you
were convicted by the jury of the murder
of Louise cow
and I must now sentence the two of you
from the time you were first put in
touch with Louise cam earlier in 2021
our jundi you told her lie after lie
you claimed to be a person of means with
the backing of a multi-millionaire
girlfriend who was going to fund the
acquisition of her properties at a level
in excess of the market value
so that Louise could provide homes for
her two sons and you could take your
share
in fact you had no assets of your own
and no rich girlfriend
you told Liars to many others connected
to Louise and wheedled your way into
acquiring possession of two cars from
another person who you befriended and
received and are right
Anna Reich described you as something of
a Walter Mitty
our gender you sought to persuade Louise
cam to enter into an arrangement whereby
the properties would be gifted to you
ostensibly as this would avoid paying
stamp Duty and other duties but in fact
because this was a result in you having
legal ownership of them without having
to pay anything
over the weeks that followed alge under
you instructed or sought to instruct a
number of different solicitors they
either refused to act or advised that
Louise cam would need separate legal
representation as the proposed
transaction clearly carried a high level
of risk for her
through your cynical deception it was
Louise Cann who ended up paying for
those Legal Services through which you
hoped to defraud her
Louise Cam's Bank ultimately refused to
make further transfers to you because
they suspected fraud
such was your dishonesty that you caused
Louie's cam to lie to her Bank and
Mortgage provider in order that you
could further profit from her
by the middle of 2021 al-jandi you had
secured a power of attorney document
signed by Louise Cam and signed tr1
transfer forms for both properties
on the material presented at Tran I am
satisfied that by the 26th of July Al
jundi U had resolved to kill Louise can
your plans had crystallized at least a
few days before
on the 24th of July you've bought an
expensive fireplace for 16 gallons Farm
Road a clear indication that you were
treating the property as your own
and on the following day you instructed
your solicitor to prepare a document
which would purport to prove that Louise
Comet entered into a contract and had
been paid
on that same day you told your mother
that Louise cam was dying of cancer
and that you were to be left her assets
in her will
it may well be that your plan was to
pretend as you subsequently claimed that
Louise cam had traveled to China
armed with the power of attorney and
transfer forms you may well have
considered that in her absence you would
have or could easily secure legal
ownership of her properties
you plainly told Ella booed you would
make a significant amount of money from
Louise Cam's death
and that a share of that money was to be
elabud's reward for killing her
elabu Jew also played a role in the
fraudent activity before the 26th of
July
you moved into the house in gallant's
Farm Road and treated it as your own
within hours of killing Louise Camp you
sold her BMW car for cash and spent some
of the proceeds on new clothes
in Tick Tock videos you posted you
mocked the wealth of Louise Cam and
showed you were enjoying the trappings
of what you and our jundi had deceived
but had achieved by your deceit
on the day that Louise cam was killed
she had driven to her house at 16
gallons Farm Road expecting to meet with
a solicitor and the parties to the
transfer of her properties
although she had been advised and warned
by her family and others not to trust
you or to engage in the process of
dealing with her property in the way she
appeared to be doing it seems that she
mistakenly believed despite these
warnings that all was above board
she spoke to her close friend Kami
Rouhani at two minutes past three that
afternoon
11 minutes later at 3 13 our jundi you
left gallant's Farm Road and went with a
girlfriend Maria amikuran to seek to set
up an alibi for the time of Louisa's
killing
Maria is someone else you deceived you
expressed your love for her and yet told
her nothing of your wife and three
children
Louise cam was killed at gallant's Farm
Road the cord of a hair dryer was used
as a ligature to strangle him as the
post-mortem examination revealed there
would have been a violent struggle when
she was attacked
other injuries were noted to her body
and it is likely she would have been
killed within some 30 to 40 seconds of
the attack starting and the ligature
used
her dead body was then left at 16
gallons Farm Road
having killed Louise Ella Burge you
moved her car from the driveway parked
it on a side street out of you
as I've mentioned our jundi you went
about seeking to provide yourself with
an alibi for the time of the murder and
elabud you drove Maria back to her
herming Coventry before returning to
London
in the course of driving Maria to our
home elabud you told her you had killed
Louise Cann she did not take you
seriously but you said you had grabbed
her from behind
the account you gave to Maria was
consistent with the way that Louise was
killed
you told Maria al-jundi had asked you to
do it as the woman owed him 2 million
pounds and our jundi had promised a
share of that money to you
you claimed to be scared of al-jundi as
you were dependent upon him for a job
and a place to live
later that day and into the early hours
of the next day the two of you wrapped
Louise's body in plastic bags under
duvet before putting the body into a
wheelie bin at 16 gallons Farm Road and
covering it with Garden rubbish
later on the 27th of July the two of you
orchestrated the move of that we live in
from 16 gallons Farm Road to 16 woodend
Road in Harrow where it was placed with
other wheelie bins also with the number
16 marks on them and other rubbish so as
to seek to cover up what you had done
and in the hope no doubt that the
contents of the wheelie bin would end up
at a local Authority rubbish site and
the atrocity you had committed would not
be traced back to you
after you had killed Louise you took her
mobile phone and bank accounts messages
were sent from her phone purporting to
be from her to her family and to her
close friends
in those messages you sought to deceive
those who loved and cared for Louise as
for her true whereabouts and what it was
that you had done to her
elabud when you were arrested in
connection with Louise's disappearance
you claimed to be helping the police
that jechu told them nothing of what had
actually happened
Al jundi you told more lies to a
solicitor about Louise again in an
effort to give yourself a cover story
you claimed that Louise had stolen money
from you
al-jandi you did not give evidence in
the trial your case was that in effect
elabud was the Killer
elabud when you gave evidence in a trial
you sought to blame al-jundu
while giving evidence you were shown to
have lied comprehensively as to what you
had done what you knew and what had
actually taken place
the two of you have rightly been
convicted on compelling evidence
in moving impact statements from
Louisa's son Gregory and from Kami
Rouhani it is clear how much Louise was
loved and admired by her family and her
friends
a woman of 71 who lumped and cared for
her sons Richard and Gregory
suffered brutal injuries at your hands
and then with complete disregard you
sought to dispose of her remains
our jundi you are 25 there are no
previous convictions recorded against
you elabud you are 28 there are only
minor matters record against you and I
propose to ignore those for the purpose
of sentence
in relation to murder the only sentence
that can be passed on you is one of life
imprisonment and that is the sentence I
will pass
the issue for this court is the minimum
term that you will each serve before you
are first considered for release
when it comes to the minimum term that
you will serve I make it plain that I am
not ordering that you are to be released
at the end of it that will be a matter
for the parole board
only when the minoan term has been
served can the parole board decide
whether it is safe to release you or not
if the board does release you you will
remain on license and liable to recall
for the rest of your lives
I'm grateful to all for the helpful
sentencing notes that have been provided
having considered the provisions of
schedule 21 of the sentencing act 2020
this case has an initial start point for
the minimum term of 30 years on the
basis this was a murder done four games
as I have indicated the two of you had
sought to defraud Louise out of her
house flats and commercial property
figures set out in texts and other
messages speak of several millions of
pounds
having identified 30 years as the
appropriate initial start point for the
minimum term there are several
aggravating factors to be considered in
this case
firstly this was an attack by you that
was extensively planned and premeditated
there was a significant degree of
planning over a lengthy period the
messages that were uncovered in the
investigation show the way in which you
took advantage of her
I also note that the attacks take the
attack takes place in the home of Louise
and her vulnerability
there were extensive efforts after
killing to conceal her body
not only did you engage in efforts to
physically conceal a body and what you
had done you also sent many many
messages to her family and closest
friends purporting to be from Louise
giving the impression she was alive and
well and had disappeared with money
which was yours
I need to be careful to avoid any double
counting as the start Point here is one
of 30 years
however the features I have identified
together do lead to a significant uplift
in the appropriate minimum term
in terms of mitigating features in this
case there are none
in my judgment this is a case with a
clear intention to kill
and the only matter to pay some regards
to is age and the lack of any
convictions or having only minor
convictions record against you
and in your case Al jundy the impact on
your wife and the children she will be
left to bring up
elevoud although it might be said the
dowjundi played the lead role in the
long-running defrauding of Louise I draw
no distinction on the sentence sentences
to be passed on the two of you
the evidence clearly shows what you did
and did willingly and that you along
with our jundi did what you did out of
greed
in my judgment and taking into account
all the aggravating and mitigating
factors I have identified
the appropriate minimum term here is one
of 35 years
the day is on remand between a rest and
now which I'm told number 549 days in
each of your cases will count towards
that sentence and so the minimum term
will be one of 35 years less the 549
days
as the statutory surcharge applies in
this case the appropriate order can be
drawn up you may go down
foreign
I should firstly pay tribute to those
police officers involved in this
thorough detailed and highly efficient
investigation
I appreciate this will have been very
much a team effort but I would wish to
acknowledge in particular the work of di
Robert Dodds he was the officer in the
case and oversaw the investigation and
identified lines of inquiry
DC malaria who was responsible for the
digital evidence the analysis of the
device overloads that downloads the
phone call and cell site data and the
production of the timeline document
DC Sophie douglich the CCTV officer
conducted labor saw the troll of
relevant errors for cameras seizing and
viewing the footage producing over 200
clips of relevant evidence as over as
well as overseeing the production of
evidence of the event and scene graphics
DC Laura guys who dealt with the witness
coordination management of the multiple
civilian Witnesses required to attend
this trial alongside the longer term
management of those key Witnesses
DC Isla Edwards the disclosure officer
in context and in case investigation
which gathered a very significant volume
of background material
and also DC David Musselwhite the family
liaison officer and responsible for the
management of a number of key Witnesses
I thank each of them most sincerely
in this trial each defendant had these
Services of an interpreter so that they
could follow proceedings in their native
language
I would wish to express particular
thanks to Mr Jonas
he has been in this courtroom for much
of the last four months covering not
only this trial but also the one that I
presided over before it that also was a
murder trial that involved the partial
defense of manslaughter by reason of
diminished responsibility
as with this trial the defendant gave
evidence over a number of days and there
was complex mental health evidence
called
the role of a court interpreter is not
just with language skills but in many
other ways too and it has been
particularly obvious to me that not only
is Mr Janus a highly proficient linguist
he is someone who understands the
process of a Tron
I knew that what is seen in court is
just a part of the role of a court
interpreter
from all that I have seen and from what
I know from those responsible for
representing Muhammad elavud Mr Jonas
you are someone with not just the
ability to provide continuous
contemporaneous translation but someone
who is equipped with the emotional
intelligence and intellectual
understanding to bring to your work
Council for the defendant have made
clear to me that you are someone who is
an excellent interpreter with a complete
understanding of the role my sincere
thanks to you and I will make sure that
a copy of these remarks are provided for
you
yep Mr Glasgow the final word of thanks
I want to express really is to you and
all at the bar for the assistance I was
provided with during this case thank you
the um sentence remarks will be uploaded
on to the system and I'll provide them
to my cloud as well thank you